the 30 years the music scene have
gathered in Austin Texas for South by
Southwest one of the world's largest
showcase festivals it's one of the
highlights of the year for the industry
and a place for the stars of tomorrow to
shine over 2000 acts by for the
attention of promoters journalists and
label managers
pop exporters here to follow some German
newcomers and to see if they can attract
new fans
liven things up
rakh even the smallest of stages and
make a name for themselves in the scene
because at the 30th edition of South by
Southwest it's show time for Germany
excited festival-goers pour into
austin-bergstrom International Airport
German DJ robot [ __ ] and singer Dalida
falls have an exciting week ahead of
them at South by Southwest they've both
been booked for a number of shows they
also hope to make lots of new contacts
with international music labels buckets
and bands part of my plan is not having
a plan at all I'm just coming here
trying to be open to things and
improvise a little I'm not here to
achieve something but to let things
happen I imagine that it's pretty crazy
and that there's tons of really great
music and what also fascinates me is
that it has this hip Austin touch at
least that's how I imagined it but for
now it's time to get some sleep and be
bright eyed for their first performance
tomorrow
Texas is the second largest state in the
US and often has been its capital since
1839 located on the Colorado River the
city has a reputation of being very
liberal and with a vibrant music scene
no wonder that South by Southwest was
founded here thirty years ago every much
people in the music business flocked to
the festival to discover the latest
trends and new talent
the festival's general manager James
miner is behind the scenes of the Austin
Convention Center well we're looking for
our artists who have a unique individual
perspective part of that what the
international acts are not being a clone
or copy it's more more about having that
individual identity
German musician Nicolas karma has come
to Austin from Berlin he's here to
perform with his band still parade but
this afternoon he takes time out to
visit straight music one of Austin's
oldest music stores Nicolas come on Matt
loves to experiment he produces all of
his own songs at his home in Berlin
the guitars instrumental determines the
instrument I learned first and the one I
can play really well but I also do all
the synthesizer arrangements myself
forgot myself that has sometimes I'd
play around with the buttons and lay
down the beats guitar so guitar isn't
the only instrument I used to write
music what are you doing
so was it to time it's evening at the
German house this is the hub for Germany
related music during the festival but if
your name's not on the list for the
Berlin party you're not coming in
it's show time for robot [ __ ] and dilly
the false how do they feel just before
going on stage yes quite nervous they
talk here and don't really listen that's
hard
it's a tough audience I mean they've
come for the music but also to talk but
the two managed to put on a good show
I didn't think that anyone would listen
but they all danced it was really good
this ranch in Austin's eastern outskirts
is well Erika Bona and her band are
staying the 29 year old artist from
Mannheim is rehearsing her rendition of
Chris Isaak's Blu Hotel in a small
chapel
it's the first time Lara has come to the
u.s. I presume Uzi gonna smile the place
really suits the music I wanted to spend
time in a nice environment and take
pictures and do some filming for my next
videos it's perfect here on from the
specific files officer Olga
punk pop electro and dark wave Lara
carbona has already experimented with
many musical styles but she discovered
her sound a long time ago
this fanciful a system I came to music
by chance someone gave me a Nirvana CD
never mind
and I put it on in flood what a crazy
sound I wanted to find out how to make
it myself
and whether there was more of it it just
sucked me here for these I'm was
equipped on 10 verse means o reason so
Karanga Tolkien lunchtime at the Salt
Lick an institution in Texas for over
150 years
Munich indie pop band kites have come to
check out the meat festival
they're grateful for a bit of time out
during the hectic festival they've got
big plans for Austin got to find a label
here for America or a booking agency to
play here more often that would be great
I turned everyone not only for America
you can get one for anywhere for Asia
Australia you can have someone
everywhere what's their first impression
of South by Southwest there are so many
people here you wouldn't meet in Germany
or that different atmosphere or
environment yes it's a bonding
experience the fact you were all here
and had a great time you can meet people
from all over
sixth Street becomes a pedestrian zone
at night Austin is the place to be for
live music no other city has such a high
concentration of live music clubs and
bars bands of all kinds play every night
of the week
and there's even more going on during
the South by Southwest festival there
are so many interesting people just
walking around and all the music is just
exploding from everywhere this is just a
big platform for anybody that has a
dream to just you know express it it's
the most exciting feeling to be next to
so many artists you don't know who they
are where they're from but you can feel
the music you can feel the energy of
each others it's the next day back at
the German house the Festival Centre for
all things German on the program today
they have concerts parties and debates
the activities here are sponsored by the
German government's funding agency for
rock pop and jazz music called in its
yet even music we've always felt it's
important that Germany presents its
music on the international stage and has
become clear over the past 30 years how
much influence of the South by Southwest
has on other international markets it's
the Gateway to the American market and
beyond one of the day's highlight in the
German house is the crack rock event
fast from Hamburg are performing founded
in 1970 the band helped pioneer the
genre of rock and electronic music
we were ahead of our time and now the
times have caught up with us we were
once a vanguard now we're gradually
becoming mainstream the ban should have
been a liter from Dusseldorf apart of
the next generation of musicians and
they were influenced by crumble the five
piece band has already been on world to
us but they didn't want to miss the trip
to Texas
the response varies a lot depending on
where you are although it's mostly quite
positive this was a special krautrock
event today so it was all German rock
but in other countries where we go it's
very different in Asia we were just a
band of five European guys
so people were intrigued to hear our
music understand again on a short
distance away
Lara cabana and her manager have an
important meeting a u.s. journalist
wants to interview them on his radio
station post in a Shia has set aside a
whole hour of airtime for the German
singer the interview will be broadcast
all over the world a radio interview is
a great opportunity to speak with
someone live I think radio is quite
different here too I can imagine it's a
great way for people to discover my
music the music was certainly an instant
hit with dinner Shia they discuss every
track on her debut album sirens he says
a good song is a good song where it
comes from is secondary
I get thousands of songs and CDs a year
and I choose what I like and that says
it all
meanwhile robot caca and daily de France
are heading to calendars boot city a
shopping paradise for cowboy fans and
tourists looking to adopt the Texas look
robot [ __ ] has lived in the US since
2014 but he's never been to a store like
this before
the pair soon get their cowboy groove on
the German DJ loves living in the US
it's been another mission heartbroken on
the Basilica but I moved to LA I was a
bit heartbroken I didn't have any plans
of conquering Hollywood I just wanted to
find myself I hardly did any music in
the first year I did a lot of meditation
workshops and road trips
I wasn't networking much either but
contacts just developed anyway and
because things were just flowing I knew
I was in the right place as daylight
begins to fade
downtown Austin gets ready for another
party marathon at the German house
Nicholas Kramer's bands still parade are
doing their first show at South by
Southwest
but they're dreamy pop sound doesn't
seem to quite fit with a party load
of course people chat but there are also
a few who listen and say you play for
them and maybe even the people who are
chatting are still enjoying the music
I understand they want to talk it's okay
back at the Austin Convention Center in
Acosta is having a look around
hundreds of music industry specialists
have set up their stands here parallel
to the live music events around the city
inna kessler heads up the initiative of
musique and was in charge of organizing
the german performances at South by
Southwest the hangman game that says
x-axis we have nearly a thousand
delegates from Germany at South by
Southwest
compared to 660 last year it's by far
the largest presentation of German
culture and creative German companies on
the American market robinson crusoe is
one such delegate he runs his own
company in berlin and is here to present
his new invention an ultra-thin control
panel that can produce various sound
effects
the so-called AK pad can be fitted to an
acoustic guitar and controlled with the
fingers while playing his demonstration
video has more than a hundred million
hits online it's been going really well
I've made a lot of contacts here had one
performance and people think what I'm
doing is really interesting
coughs meanwhile are getting ready to
play at shiner saloon the band only got
together a year ago but if there's one
thing they've learned in that time it's
that musicians have to be patient at
major festivals like South by Southwest
the schedule can easily get delayed here
and there for the tour we wait for the
plane we're waiting now we went at home
and in the end we play for half an hour
but it's mostly worth it
at 11:00 p.m. they're finally on
American music journalist Alex Mayo Lo
has been waiting to see the German indie
pop group live well the strength of
kites is they're very professional of
what they do I mean they they're
obviously amazing at their instruments
right they look great they're well
rehearsed and they perform their songs
beautifully as soon as the show's over
they have to clear the stage in the
backyard of shiner saloon they're now
free to chill out so what do they think
of South by Southwest but you need to do
it if you're ready you have to take the
plunge you have to have the right team
which knows how everything works here I
think if we just been here for ourselves
we'd have looked a bit stupid at times
Nick Cooper and young fella are at the
other end of town they work for the
North German festival buck an open-air
the biggest metal festival in the world
they're here to network and check out
new hard rock bands it's their dream job
if you want to do it then it's the best
job in the world but it's not 9:00 to
5:00 you're out 18 on 19 hours a day
meeting people sometimes you're
shattered but that's what it comes down
to meetings meetings business deals we
talked about possible future plans about
small bands big bands it definitely
makes sense for us to be here to show
our faces tonight a u.s. metal legend is
playing at Elysium crowbar is one of
Nick Hooper's favorite band
throw our finishing with Yummie they've
got incredible power the part of the New
Orleans sludge metal scene they're great
they've never played at our festival but
if we could get them that would be ace
it's noon the next day at Long Branch in
just outside of Austin not exactly it
still parades favorite time for a gig
but every minute counts at this
week-long festival they have to set up
everything themselves for the
performance and they don't even know if
anyone will turn up to the newcomers gig
just hope it's a cool show and we hope
it'll be relaxed they think it's really
important that we're relaxed even though
the audience is small the right people
are here professionals in the scene who
won't still parade to make it
internationally like their label manager
who's traveled from Manchester
we certainly look up to the the bands
coming out of Germany because it's also
very vibrant but also in certain ways on
the edge and we've always loved the
certainly the feel of Berlin music seen
its rivals any music scene in the UK
sightseeing in Austin
Lara carbonia has one more day to her
concert so she's making the most of the
city's non-musical attractions like the
Colorado River and a bat display
it's much attachment I see it was
beautiful when the bats came out from
under the bridge and flew off they
looked like the Dementors in Harry
Potter it was great the boat ride makes
for some nice time out but the
performance is on Laura's mind I'm not
nervous right now
but that could change I think by the
time we do the soundcheck an hour before
the show my heart will be racing a bit
electric producer robot [ __ ] and singer
Delia de France are heading on stage
tonight at the Empire control room
kites have turned up as a surprise to
see them play robot cough just remixed a
song for them but this is the first time
that met face to face otherwise though
the club's looking pretty empty I'm a
bit skeptical it's nice out and there's
a lot going on empty here so no one
wants to come in people look and think
nothing's happening so they mean
the room slowly starts to fill up robot
caucuses to playing at festivals in
front of thousands of people is he
disappointed about tonight large crowds
are less personal when you're in front
of thousands of people and they're
making loads of noise it does sound good
and feel good but when five or six
people are there dancing all night and
they come to you after the show to tell
you what your music means to them that
has a great significance that happened
tonight and it's great they're
professional stunt here in Austin is
done and now Nicklaus karma can enjoy a
taste of the American lifestyle after
the South by Southwest festival he wants
to take the band to California to do a
few gigs on the fly he's feeling
positive about their time here so far
being in America really feels like a big
step forward for us it's the first time
we've played live here and we got lots
of really positive feedback we're happy
people came to see our concerts it's the
final day here for Nick Cooper and yonk
feel from Rukn festival initiative a
music has invited them to the Convention
Center to join a discussion panel on
heavy metal in Germany young Kiel wants
to promote vac and open airs work with
emerging artists I think it's really
exciting for the entire heavy metal
scene the genre has no limits I think
that's exciting important so we'll
continue our work and stay active the
music experts spend an hour discussing
Germany's hot rock scene Yanis a burger
for the biggest metal festival in the
world and his experience means he's in
high demand with heavy metal fans as fun
because they were loyal they're friendly
yeah I mean they uh what they need is
loud music beer and meet the parent
often found hanging about in conference
rooms is different from the live music
business but you can find out about
interesting ideas that have nothing to
do with the scene
but it's all actually happening
elsewhere that spawned our biggest party
including a wonderful like at Alice in
Trinity Street the countdowns on for
Lara carbona this is her first
performance in this live music
metropolis we've got a 40 minute set
ahead new sweaty and very loud It's
Showtime she's playing 90 songs many of
which are on her debut album sirens it
was also released in the US and Canada
and her North American label has big
projects
the long-term plan here is to get her to
come back for a tour probably in the
fall probably do the eastern US and
Canada that's our goal
Phil Erica Bonilla the trip to Austin
has already been worth it the head of an
Australian label saw her and her signed
her del Amanda
this is a pure fondness lighted some
cones a common wild that people come to
a concert and stay right to the end and
of course it's great when people give
you a high-five afterwards and say it
was cool that feels great
their time in Austin is drawing to a
close but what a week it's been for
these German acts for many it's a big
step forward on their way to the top